hey guys it is the 18th of July today
I'm a slightly less sick version of just
and here's the gaming news that matter
fandom code the publishers behind such
franchises as Tekken and Dark Souls have
a new IP they're ready to announce next
month Namco have confirmed they will
reveal a new IP free quote Western
audience during games come in August the
publisher will also be bringing along
Dragonball xenoverse - and the yet to be
released console version of Tekken 7 so
you can have a play if you find yourself
at the event on the topic of Tekken 7
Game Director Katsuhiro Harada announced
two new characters at the Evo fighting
game tournament in Las Vegas this past
weekend Master Raven and the far less
glorious named but probably familiar Bob
herb is back with his freestyle karate
moves and a wide range of attacks while
Master Raven is a newcomer who appears
to have been inspired by Tekken 5s Raven
you can check out how each of them fight
in our story and games blood trophies
for a Playstation full version of Dead
Rising have appeared online suggesting
that the game could be slated for
release EXO phase posted a list of 51
trophies which of the same as those
included in the original xbox 360
release of the game but to feature new
artwork now in a statement against what
Capcom have confirmed the Dead Rising is
officially coming to Xbox one ps4 and PC
while dead rising 2 and Dead Rising 2
off the record will arrive on Xbox one
and ps4
they're already playable on PC Capcom
and Microsoft unveiled Dead Rising 4 at
e3 this year which is set to release
exclusively on Xbox one and Windows 10
in December this is however a timed
exclusive so it's possible the game
could make its way over to other
platforms eventually finally Microsoft
has announced when you can get your
hands on the Xbox one s the $400 2
terabyte model will hit shelves on
august 2 while the 350 dollar one
terabyte model and the $300 500 gigabyte
model will arrive in December of this
year
the Xbox one S is 40% smaller than the
current Xbox one model
comes with an internal power supply it
supports HDR and comes with an updated
xbox one controller which features a new
textured grip and better Wireless and
Bluetooth support if you like the sound
of that you can pick up the controller
separately for 50 bucks when it arrives
on august 2 so far the only color
announced is white but the 2 terabyte
version does come with the stamp so at
least you got that all Xbox one games
accessories and Xbox Live services are
supported on the new Xbox one s console
we shot ahead to GameSpot's four stories
on for Apple's new update and crackdown
3 assuming the plague hasn't got me I
will be back with more news for you
tomorrow